bonjour à tous donc aujourd'hui on va
parler d'un sujet un petit peu
informatique puisque c'est mon domaine
de compétence
les tests unitaires alors moi je viens
du domaine du calcul haute performance
donc un domaine on a tendance à
travailler avec ses immenses machines
qui peuvent remplir une salle entière
avec les processeurs les plus récents du
monde et sur ces machines là une
tendance à faire tourner des très très
vieux logiciel qui date plutôt des
années 80 donc une époque où le génie
logiciel n'était absolument pas ce qu'il
est aujourd'hui c'est à dire que les
tests unitaires étaient complètement
absents et c'est assez souvent assez
frustrante travail sur ce genre de
logiciel donc je vais essayer de vous
motiver un petit peu vous qui être
étudiant en sciences qu'ici à technolac
demain vous serez peut-être amené à
développer des logiciels et donc si je
peux vous motiver à faire des tests
unitaires pour vous simplifier la vie je
serais ravi alors je vous rassure tout
de suite on va pas rentrer dans le
technique
pas question ici de parler de fonction
et d'exemples de code
on va parler d'un point de vue
philosophique et je vais essayer de vous
partager les lunettes à travers
lesquelles je regarde ces tests
unitaires
on va commencer par un petit concept
c'est ce qu'on appelle la dette
technique donc pour la ramener un
problème de la vie de tous les jours
entre guillemets je prendre cet exemple
donc le projet manhattan dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler quand il
s'agissait de fabriquer la bombe
nucléaire aux états unis et on était un
petit peu à la bourre à cette époque on
voulait la voir vite très vite et donc
pour la gestion des déchets n'étaient
pas très sensibilisés à l'écologie à
l'époque et c'est ce genre de gestion
qu'on avait en prenez les déchets on
faisait un trou et on prenait un camion
de personnes ayant vidé les déchets dans
le trou pour les déchets liquides une
grosse cuve et hop pareil sous le sable
et on enterre tous à 55 ans plus tard
c'est ce qu'on appelle la dette
technique
aujourd'hui on va gérer ses déchets
puisqu'on ne sait pas où ils sont c'est
pas qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans et donc
pour le gouvernement américain s'est à
peu près entre sur les derniers rapports
de l'année dernière entre 300 et 600
milliards de dollars qui doivent être
dépensés jusqu'en 2046 pour gérer la
crise sur place donc ça c'est vraiment
le concept de dette technique quelque
chose qu'on a fait à larache et qu'on
doit ensuite payer plus tard en
informatique c'est extrêmement commun
souvent on développe son logiciel très
rapidement et puis ensuite on en paye le
prix
dans les années à venir donc pour
revenir l'informatique justement ça a
été étudié par capteurs zone ce qui a
pris 13 villes projets informatiques
dans le monde entier et calculer un
petit peu le coup qui étaient dépensés à
corriger les bugs
fonction de l'âge du logiciel donc à
l'époque dans les années 90 ans
développé le logiciel donc c'est là
qu'on a introduit l'essentiel des bugs
et ensuite on faisait les tests états
pourront commencer à découvrir les bugs
voire et corrigé puis le logiciel entrer
en production
et là on commence à avoir des bugs qui
sont relativement critique à imaginer
votre banque
si un aveugle qui empêche toute les
cartes de crédit de fonctionner pendant
une journée la perte financière est
énorme
donc on voit sur cette courbe une
exponentielle sur le coût de correction
d'un bug qu on le corrige tard et plus
ça va nous coûter cher
après j'étais étudiant je me disais
l'exponentielle c'est quand même un
petit peu exagéré
maintenant je suis dans le monde
professionnel je me dis qu'en fait c'est
effectivement réel imaginez votre banque
qui fonctionne pas pendant une journée
ou google qui fonctionne ou pas pendant
une heure c'est quasi c'est directement
des millions de dollars qui sont perdus
alors on va essayer de d'imaginer qu'on
a un ingénieur automobile
pas tout à fait du logiciel justement
pour comparer à quelque chose qui fait
un peu plus sensé qui va vous faire un
petit peu qu'on pense que c'est le test
unitaire
si on est le fabricant de la boîte à
vitesse de la voiture
on a plusieurs méthodes pour procéder la
première c'est pas faire le test du tout
on a vraiment une boîte à vitesses on la
met dans une voiture et enlevant la
voiture aux clients évidemment si vous
êtes un client d'une voiture vous serez
assez déçu d'avoir une voiture qui est
conçu comme ça il est peu probable
d'ailleurs que vous l'achetiez
malheureusement en informatique c'est
souvent ce genre de choses qu'on fait on
développe un logiciel en code à la va
vite
c'est particulièrement vrai quand on
fait une thèse en informatique ou en
physique et ensuite on donne le logiciel
à quelqu'un qui va l'utiliser
pas de test et tout va bien ou pas bien
suivant l'utilisation qui va en être
fait après si on veut être un petit peu
plus sérieux on va faire ce qu'on
appelle un test d'intégration dans le
cadre de la voiture automobile c'est ce
qu'on pourrait appeler le crash tests
ont fabriqué une voiture entière et on
l'envoie contre un mur si tout se passe
bien bas le logiciel marche
s'il ya des problèmes elle va falloir
analyser quel est le problème alors en
automobile à un crash test mais bien sûr
ça va prendre plusieurs mois pour
fabriquer le prototype en informatique
on a tendance à beaucoup fonctionné avec
les tests d'intégration puisque un test
intégration s'est lancé le logiciel et
ça ça prend quelques secondes seulement
le problème qu'on oublie en général
c'est qu'ensuite une fois qu'on a une
batterie de tests par exemple de dix
mille tests d'intégration c'est ce que
j'avais pendant ma thèse est bien une
fois que la voiture elle a craché qui a
eu un bug il va falloir aller débugger
ça et trouver je viens
problème le problème c'est qu'on a la
voiture entière qui s'est crashé contre
un mur et potentiellement un million de
lignes de codes qui ont planté
question quelle est la ligne de code qui
a planté quand on est au milieu d'un
million l'une est là on va penser à
avoir quelque chose qui coûte
extrêmement cher est extrêmement
désagréable à travailler potentiellement
par le soir avec la tête la tête comme
une pastèque
donc la meilleure méthode normalement
c'est de faire ce qu'on appelle un banc
d'essai si on était ingénieur automobile
c'est à dire un test militaires devront
attester une petite partie de la boîte à
vitesses dans un contexte virtuel dont
classe pour la boîte à vitesses sont là
mais sur un sur un support on marche un
moteur électrique de celui on peut
regarder directement ce qui se passe on
n'a pas besoin d'ouvrir le capot de la
voiture de démonter des pièces pour
aller regarder comment tout ça
fonctionne autre intérêt on peut mettre
par exemple une caméra thermique des
micros pour mesurer les vibrations de la
boîte à vitesses et voir qu'on améliore
notre boîte à vitesses avec des
métriques chose qu'on va pouvoir vendre
à son client ensuite alors j'ai parlé
tests militaires tu as d'intégration
vous voir quelque chose sont pas aussi
binaire le test militaire s'est par
exemple testé à un pignon tout seul et
le test d'intégration tester d'opinion
ensemble on pourrait dire c'est un petit
peu comme s'il y avait deux mondes un le
rouge et le bleu états unitaires et
d'intégration en fait les choses soient
un petit peu plus linéaire puisque on va
tester à un pignon puis de pignons puis
catherine joncquez du pignon puis toute
la bio et la boîte à vitesses puis la
voiture en entière tout ça ça forme un
gradient en fait où on pourrait
quasiment toutes appelé test unitaire
puisque le test unitaire pour le
développeur de la boîte à vitesses n'est
pas forcément un test unitaire pour le
développeur de la voiture alors qu'est
ce que j'ai ressenti la première fois
que l'on m'a parlé de tests unitaires ça
avait l'air cool c'est un petit peu
comme si un ami m'avait dit abattu à
faire un marathon et puis tu verras tu
vas te sentir bien dans son corps et une
cravache mans plus simple et tu te
sentiras bien donc j'ai été faire un
marathon qui vont chez a pas trop
comment m'y prendre c'est la première
fois que faisait les tests unitaires et
donc j'ai couru en retenant mon souffle
ont forcément si je retiens mon souffle
au bout de 2 au bout d'une minute à peu
près j'ai commencé à avoir un point de
côté je vais m'arrêter je dirais non
mais c'est pas possible tu ton truc est
ce que c'est ça me prend du temps c'est
difficile je suis pas content en fait
c'est parce que je me l'étais mal pris
parce que pour être des éternités des
tests militaires il va falloir hisser
les bons outils la bonne méthode de
travail
et forcément ça ça va demander à
travailler travailler travailler pour
l'apprendre est arrivé à l'appliquer
correctement
typiquement il ya des disciplines à
avoir donc il ya des phrases à bannir de
son vocabulaire par exemple ceci est un
poc ont souvent qu'on a un poc proof of
concept on se dit bon c'est pas grave ce
sera pas utilisé donc j'ai pas testé
unitairement et je vous ferai et est
plus tard pas de chance quand on fait ça
dans une entreprise en général une fois
que le pot qui commence à marcher tout
de suite il ya un client on l'a vendu ça
y est et maintenant on est à des bugs
élevé à débugger programme et on n'a
absolument plus de temps pour faire ces
tests unitaires
au-delà de ça qu'on a fait un poc s'il
est déjà fait mais il va falloir passer
une semaine deux semaines voire un mois
à faire que d'écrire états unis terre ce
qui est extrêmement frustrant et
désagréable à faire c'est l'erreur que
j'avais fait la première fois que j'ai
fait mes tests
une petite phrase commune aussi cette
fonction là elle est trop courte pas la
peine de la tester pas de bol quand on
fait les tests unitaires on se rend
compte que les fonctions les plus buggé
souvent justement ce sont les fonctions
courte et les plus embêtante à débugger
puisqu'elles sont appelés par tous en
général
cette fonction est trop complexe si elle
est trop complexe en général si vous
vous y êtes mal pris que vous avez pas
fait de tests unitaires puisque les
tests unitaires sont normalement là pour
vous empêcher de faire des fonctions
entre complexe donc si vous avez ce
genre de phrases normalement c'est que
vous êtes sortis de la méthodologie
alors si on imagine un petit peu
l'ensemble des espaces de code que vous
pouvez implémenter puisque en
informatique qui a toujours mille et une
façons de faire une faire les choses il
ya des façons qui sont extrêmement
compliquées ou en risque effectivement
ne jamais arriver au bout de
l'implémentation on risque de se casser
la figure et de faire foirer le projet
un peu plus simple si on s'y prend bien
on à la zone orange des buts atteignable
c'est à dire qu'on s'y est mal pris mais
mal en bonne en ont peut arriver à la
fin peut-être en sept ans tordu une
cheville en route
si on s'y prend un petit peu mieux quand
on fait un peu plus de génie logiciel en
général on va avoir la zone des tests
faisable donc là en général c'est ce que
c'est la zone dans laquelle on se balade
qu'on n'a pas tests unitaires
les six réalité ce militaire à faire
vraiment se restreindre à faire des
choses très simples qu'on peut tester
unitairement faire du kiss keep it
stupide en steeple comme on dit et là on
va pouvoir faire nos tests nos tests
unitaires de manière tellement agréable
donc c'est à des intérêts des tests
unitaires sais que ça va nous permettre
de rester dans cette zone de test simple
je rêvais j'y reviendrai ensuite
l'avantagé aussi c'est qu'en restant
dans les zones simple on évite ce qui se
passe dans la zone dans les zones bleues
et orange c'est d'avoir besoin
régulièrement de super héros d'un conte
un logiciel complexe souvent dans une
équipe on a le héros qu'on va les
appeler qu'on a des problèmes que
personne n'arrivait à résoudre
toujours dans les équipes on a souvent
ce genre de profil une personne qui s'en
tire mieux avec la complexité
si on reste dans la zone t stable en
général comme on a fait les choses plus
simplement on a un tout petit peu un
petit peu moins besoin des héros alors
attention tout de même si on appelle les
héros souvent les héros ils ont tendance
à rajouter de la complexité
donc quand on est dans la zone bleue et
orange sur fais pas attention on va
finir par dériver vers la zone rouge où
là on a besoin non plus dans un seul
héros mais d'une équipe de héros est là
en général ça se termine assez mal non
pourquoi est ce que les tests unitaires
ça nous permet de garder un code simple
c'est que ça va nous interdire certains
types de d'optimisation typiquement donc
par exemple si on prend une forme d'une
fonction pour implémenter ce qu'on fait
le matin quand on se lève donc on va
vouloir boire son café aller promener
les chiens et ouvrir la porte du garage
pour partir faire son trajet vers le
travail si on avait un bon informaticien
normalement on découpe bien ces trois
fous ces trois étapes en trois fonctions
distinctes ou groupes de fonction et on
fait bien notre travail
alors quand d'un calcul haute
performance on a bien l'optimisation 1
on est des gens qui aiment bien la
complexité on aime bien faire des choses
qui vont vite et donc pour aller plus
vite on peut se dire pendant que je bois
mon café je peux prendre déjà la laisse
qui permet d'aller prendre le chien la
mettre sur l'épaule et la clé dans la
poche pour aller ouvrir la porte du
garage donc comme ça j'ai déjà fait état
pendant du buffet mon café et je suis
prête à les faire pour la suite
problème quand je vais vouloir faire un
test unitaire de mon chien maintenant je
suis obligé d'appeler ma fonction qui
fait le café pour avoir la laisse dans
la main donc on voit que les
optimisations précoce qu'on pourrait
faire vont venir nous nous empêcher de
faire nos tests unitaires correctement
et là le test militaire et un petit peu
comme un enseignant il va faire un petit
peu un rappel est fait gaffe là ce que
tu as fait c'est pas très propre qui
feraient mieux de découper correctement
ton travail
donc c'est un petit peu comme un
enseignant le test unitaire alors
justement il va éviter l'augmentation de
complexité à concord au code un code la
complexité du logiciel naturellement à
l'augmenter jusqu'au moment où on a
besoin justement de ces super héros
si on a les tests unitaires ce qu'on va
faire et en général c'est plutôt que
quand le code va augmenter à un moment
donné on va faire ce qu'on appellera
refactoring dire simplifier son code
donc la complexe teva début et puis
réaugmenter ont refermé factoring à le
diminuer et ainsi de suite
de façon à maintenir une complexité du
code qui reste contrôlé
un autre intérêt des tests unitaires
c'est que ça nous évite l'effet tunnel
ses terres vous implémentez une fonction
et c'est seulement dans six mois quand
vous aurez implémenter tout le reste
sourd vous allez savoir si elle marche
avec les tests unitaires comme vous l'a
attesté immédiatement vous savez
immédiatement votre fonction marche est
en permanence vous savez où vous en êtes
donc l'effet tunnel disparaît vous
n'avez pas besoin d'attendre six mois
pour savoir si ce que vous avez fait
c'est en tout cas en train d'aller dans
la bonne direction
donc il ya plein d'intérêt comme ça pour
les tests unitaires j'ai pas les lister
tous ici parce que ce serait trop long
mais au delà d'avoir testé le cogne à
plein d'un prof de problèmes qui se
résolvent automatiquement quand on suit
ce genre de démarche et notamment comme
on a choisi des choses plus simples on
évite de faire de la varappe
c'est à dire que vous allez permettre à
des développeurs qui sont moins
d'experts de venir travailler avec vous
vous allez plutôt faire un c'est un
petit peu comme la tournette vous savez
qu'il ya deux faces ya la phase où vous
allez besoin de faire de l'escaladé la
phase où vous avez un joli chemin un
petit peu plus doux qui permet d'arriver
au sommet et si vous prenez le chemin
qui est un petit peu plus douce est
intéressant puisque vous pouvez avoir
une équipe un peu plus diverses avec des
gens peut-être moins techniques qui vont
venir vous aider par exemple les
stagiaires quand ils vont rentrer dans
votre projet ils vont avoir beaucoup
plus de facilité à rentrer dans le code
avec du feedback des garde-fous au cas
où ils cassent quelque chose donc vous
aussi en tant que encadrants de du
stagiaire vous allez pouvoir être un peu
plus lâche et le laisser se débrouiller
puisque vous savez que si jamais ils
cassent quelque chose vous avez un
feedback il ya vous dira attention là il
ya un problème et donc le stagiaire à un
peu plus autonomie assez rapidement
c'est donc intéressant et quand on a
plusieurs comme ça on peut
éventuellement avec une équipe arrivée
allait marcher sur l'eau et faire un
projet génial alors juste pour mettre
une petite photo de ce que j'aime bien
j'aime beaucoup la plongée et donc on a
l'occasion en plongée de découvrir ces
jolies flabeau line qui sont des petites
limaces et aujourd'hui on voudrait les
protéger seulement dans notre monde on a
beaucoup de choses à changer et donc si
on rentre le soir avec la tête comme une
pastèque parce qu on a passé notre
journée à faire des corrections de bugs
compliqué on va pas avoir le temps de
réfléchir à comment est-ce qu'on va
sauver ces espèces avec les tests
militaires en général quand on rentre le
soir on a l'esprit libre et donc la
possibilité peut être de réfléchir à
comment est ce qu'on pourrait faire
évoluer notre monde
voilà donc j'espère que je vous ai
convaincu un petit peu sur céda
sanitaire et j'espère que demain si
jamais on vous propose d'en faire eh
bien vous dirai oui voilà